if you have only good tattoos I don't
[ __ ] with you because that means you're
mad new-school newbie with it
wet-behind-the-ears you had fresh skin
now you have all these new tattoos from
the best people whoop-dee-doo get a bad
tattoo get a bad one
[Music]
my first tattoo was my daughter's name
across my chest yeah I mean I didn't go
crazy like so maybe four years ago five
years ago and a couple of little things
here I had a couple things here but then
I just said [ __ ] you I need to be
decorated this body needs to be on a
mental you can't see the side on the
back from here right here I'm normal if
I go there then you you see a display of
art this one on the side of my head is
pretty sickening a howling lone wolf
right there
I wanted pretty [ __ ] sick this one's
pretty out of this [ __ ] control
that's freedom
that's me leaving with skulls flying
wherever I need to go skulls and snakes
and any Eagles are just cool imagery
traditional tattoo imagery is really
something I like skulls like the cracks
in the skulls and the different shades
and way you could make it look like
really nuts something [ __ ] biker
about it and outlaws you know
[Music]
dan Santoro Matador
I picked this off the wall in the Bronx
[ __ ] a chart of the life of a lamb
with Greek lettering a pyramid a [ __ ]
Yasser Arafat crocodile Zeus the first
car ever ball with rap money
it's an m5 wagon you got to have bad
tattoos that used to be good but it's
pretty bad actually it's a bad Goldeneye
gun Reapers Devils skulls snakes
crashing planes Panthers that have
[ __ ] mind-control [ __ ] on their eyes
a [ __ ] war tank scorpion Sagittarius
I saw that on DMT
it's a [ __ ] DMT trippy type of Archer
but I got Libra scale for my girl and
she got the archer on her arm she's a
Libra I mean you don't get your girl
tattooed on you you get your actual girl
tattooed on you I mean that's a classic
design it happens to look exactly like
my beautiful lady and she's holding
cocoa which is even crazier so I had to
get it on me
[Music]
this [ __ ] guy is crazy they cut
through my jack when I had surgery
that's the creeper wolf he's a creep
he's the bedroom wolf he's in pajamas
Javier Rodriguez from Spain
the little Murcielago with the skull
Godzilla versus Berkeley I had that
poster hanging in my house since 92 I
still got it in my house I got the
Neagle I tattooed my man the other day
actually we traded he gave me this
Neagle and I gave him a tattoo on his
foot first time other the tattooed
anybody
oh yeah the Barry Bonds tattoo right
here is uh it's just in remembrance of
me always having to be a beast this is
just beast mode batting average 328
Homer 73 RBIs 137 was nuts 73 home runs
you just [ __ ] blew everyone's mind
he's been juicing for years but I don't
feel that there's anything wrong with
that that there's a tattoo under there
that I hated and I got it covered
I got it blasted with a [ __ ]
humongous gorilla face that's how much I
hated it that I threw a gorillas face on
my wrist [ __ ] there's all stories behind
all these things
it'll take [ __ ] hours man you've seen
all them shits go get tattooed